[Music]
here's to a monster opening weekend not
wait for this movie I was with the cast
of crazy rich Asians in Vegas back in
April now the hype about this movie is
real the critics loved it and for one of
its stars ocean's 8 alum Aquafina it's
been one crazy rich rise to the top just
five years ago aquafina whose real name
is nour alum was making $9 an hour
working at a vegan market when she
started posting funny rap videos to
YouTube after her videos went viral she
landed a few small TV roles before
getting a part in the 2016 sequel to
neighbours fast forward to this summer
the 30 year old released a new
critically acclaimed rap album landed a
role in oceans 8 and tonight you can see
her steal scenes in crazy rich Asians
alongside the hangovers can jump how
proud of you is your family bachelor in
the romantic comedy aquafina tries to
help her bestie fit in with her
boyfriend's crazy rich family have you
guys had your experiences bringing
somebody home to meet the family my
family just wants me to find someone I
mean they're like oh oh and he'll do
anybody she needs to move out you so you
live with your family stuff you don't
wanna move moving out I'm tired of the
Roth IRA it I'm gonna withdraw from it
aquafina rocks a short blonde wig for
the role and her family was it exactly
feeling it
they laughed yeah laughed mockingly and
then told me that he's like why don't
you just act like well I think she met
her in a good way
a normal conversation like why are you
right right but League man Harry Golding
says without the wig she had a tough
time on set nobody recognized her
without the wig on so she come on the
SAP without the wig on and the crew do
you need to know it's me a Covina trust
me people will know who she is after
this movie and by the way Henry was a
hairdresser an a TV show host
he hosted several travel programs this
is his first movie ever
[Music]